salut, je suis John Green, je suis l'auteur du
livre The Fault in Our Stars qui est maintenant en
train d'être transformé en film oh mon dieu
on dirait que nous volons rien n'a jamais ressemblé
à ça dans toute l'histoire humaine
tout le monde ici  cet ensemble ressent une
énorme responsabilité envers l'histoire
et envers ses lecteurs qui a été si
important pour le film d'accord peut
-être que ce sera notre toujours,
vous savez, j'ai moi aussi une rencontre habillée avec
ce mr.  Peter Van Houten et moi
pensons vraiment que cela aurait beaucoup de sens de le
rencontrer sans la fille qui m'a présenté
le livre en premier lieu maintenant que
suis-je dieu c'est incroyable de voir une histoire
qui pendant longtemps n'existait que dans mon
imagination devenir  visible je pense que
ça va être un super film je pense que
c'est une adaptation très fidèle de mon
histoire